j'en viens à ce qui va être le coeur de
notre actualité cette semaine la niche
parlementaire nous avons eu les passages
en commission de nos textes la semaine
dernière où nous avons assisté dans bien
des cas un fonds communs la République
en marché le RN avec le refus
d'augmenter le SMIC à 1600 euros net
alors que je crois que c'est une urgence
forte dans le pays avec un vote contre
la location d'autonomie pour les jeunes
à hauteur du seuil de pauvreté
c'est-à-dire 1102 euros par mois contre
les mesures d'aide en faveur des plus
pauvres et avec des votes contre de la
macronie sur l'urgence démocratique sur
le fait baisser le seuil sur le
référendum d'initiative partagé et sur
la loi anticoncentration des médias
tandis que le RN courageusement
s'abstenait la semaine dernière je veux
dire ici avec force comme je l'ai redis
à la Conférence des Présidents ce matin
que je déplore l'obstruction
anti-démocratique qui est fait sur
l'unique journée que nous avons pour
choisir l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale sur cette unique journée on
nous nous retrouvons avec 26 amendements
sur uber files 112 amendements sur le
SMIC 230 amendements sur l'IVG 560
amendements sur la corrida et je
pourrais ensuite continuer avec les
autres textes je le dis cette
obstruction est non seulement
anti-démocratique mais elle serait
extrêmement dommageable pour notre
assemblée puisque cela voudrait dire à
la fin que vous vous retrouverez avec
aucun des groupes de cette assemblée qui
ne pourraient passer un texte en entier
dans leur niche parlementaire je crois
que c'est dangereux et que cela poursuit
un double objectif d'abord d'empêcher
tout débat sur des questions majeures je
pense notamment au débat de société sur
la question de la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG pour lequel neuf Français sur
dix sont favorables à l'inscrire dans la
Constitution ou sur la corrida ou là
aussi 90% des Français se déclarent
favorables à l'interdiction de la
corrida avec mise à mort et puis
d'empêcher que ne soit voté des mesures
qui sont des mesures d'urgence sociale
je vais vous parler de la location
d'autonomie d'un véritable statut de
fonctionnaire pour les aesh ou encore de
mesures en faveur des plus pauvres sur
la question de la rénovation thermique
et de la gratuité des premiers mètres
cubes d'eau
cette obstruction est d'autant plus
déplorable que nous avions en commission
réussie à obtenir une victoire
historique puisque nous avions obtenu le
fait de gagner la la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour inscrire le droit
à l'IVG et à la contraception dans la
Constitution et ce n'est pas moi toute
seule qui le demande je vous disais neuf
Français sur 10 sont favorables une
pétition recueille déjà 150 000
signataires qui le demandent et je redis
ce que nous disons maintenant depuis des
mois c'est-à-dire que nous voulons que
le gouvernement dépose un projet de loi
constitutionnel puisque vous savez la
différence entre une proposition de loi
sur la constitution et un projet de loi
qui viendrait du gouvernement c'est que
ça permettrait d'aller beaucoup plus
rapidement d'éviter un référendum et
donc la libération de parole de
mouvement antichois et permettrait à la
France d'être le premier pays au monde à
inscrire la Constitution l'avortement
dans sa constitution
notre niche parlementaire aura d'ores et
déjà au moins il le mérite de même avant
son examen de démasquer les 50 nuances
de droites alliés pour continuer quoi
qu'il en coûte la politique de
maltraitance sociale animale et
démocratique de ce gouvernement et je
vous donne rendez-vous le 24 pour la
suite de cette niche en espérant
qu'entre temps des groupes et choisir
raisonnablement de retirer leurs
amendements d'obstruction